c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la visite éclair de la
CEDEAO hawagadougou la délégation
conduite par son émissaire Mamadou
Issoufou n'a pas quitté l'aéroport
l'ancien président du Niger a pris la
parole avant de reprendre l'avion il a
évoqué les risques d'affrontement éviter
au sein de l'armée lors du coup d'État
dans le même temps des manifestations
hostiles à la CEDEAO et à la France se
sont tenues dans la capitale nous y
retrouverons nous envoyer spéciaux dans
un instant la reprise du procès des
massacres du 28 Septembre 2009 en Guinée
il avait été reporté d'une semaine à
l'ouverture pour permettre aux avocats
de mieux se préparer le capitaine Moussa
Dadis Camara et c'est quoi accusé était
tous présents dans la salle d'audience
nous serons à Conakry dans ce journal
et à la fin de cette édition nous vous
emmènerons à la rencontre de route baby
l'ivoirienne et championne du monde de
taekwondo sa réussite fait des émules le
taekwondo est devenu le deuxième sport
en Côte d'Ivoire après le football
la CEDEAO n'a pu finalement effectuer
qu'une escale à Ouagadougou la mission
de l'organisation West africaine
conduite par l'ancien président du Niger
Mahamadou Issoufou n'a pas quitté
l'aéroport en parallèle dans la capitale
burkinabè plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants c'était rassemblés pour
crier gloire à Moscou et scander des
slogans hostiles à la CEDEAO et à la
France nous envoyer spéciaux s'ils sont
rendus retour sur cette journée avec
Ange nomenyo
la CEDEAO voulait garder contact avec la
jointe militaire et s'assurer de la
poursuite de sa mission au Burkina Faso
ce n'était pas chose facile puisque
toute la ville a été
remplis de manifestants campés devant la
présidence et à plusieurs endroits de la
ville c'est manifestants ne voulaient
pas que la CEDEAO entre dans le pays il
reprochait à l'institution sous
régionale de ne pas agir quand il le
faut la CEDEAO n'est plus la CEDEAO des
peuples des populations c'est devenu la
CEDEAO des présidents
alors
nous ne voulons pas que la CEDEAO
dérange
le capitaine et ses hommes la rencontre
entre la CEDEAO et la jante a finalement
eu lieu à l'aéroport l'institution sous
régionale à dépêcher cette mission pour
entrer en contact avec la jante il
s'agit de poursuivre sa mission au sein
du pays à savoir la reconquête des
territoires sous influence djihadiste la
résolution de la crise humanitaire et le
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel
le pays était
[Musique]
je dirais
au bord du gouffre
et
le moindre dérapage
lui aurait précipité un accord avait été
trouvé entre l'Ancien Régime et la
CEDEAO accord qui limite la durée de la
transition à deux ans reste à savoir si
le nouveau pouvoir va suivre à la lettre
cet accord
si la CEDEAO n'a pas approuvé le coup
d'État le capitaine Ibrahim Traoré a
reçu le soutien d'un homme il y avait
gueni frigo jean homme d'affaires proche
du Kremlin et fondateur du groupe
paramilitaire Wagner il en a il a en
substance félicité chaleureusement et
saluer le nouvel homme fort du pouvoir
27 soldats ont été tués c'est le nouveau
bilan de l'attaque de gaskindé dans le
nord du Burkina Faso le 26 septembre
dernier un convoi de ravitaillement à
destination de la ville de Djibo
capitale régionale enclavé dans le nord
du pays et sous pression depuis
plusieurs années des groupes djihadistes
avaient été attaqués le précédent bilan
faisait état d'au moins 11 soldats tués
et d'une cinquantaine de civils disparus
et dans la région on ne meurt pas que
sous les balles ou les bombes les
djihadistes s'aiment aussi la fin selon
une association de la région de Sum 8
enfants sont morts par manque de
nourriture à Djibo cette ville sous
blocus djihadiste depuis février dernier
ne peut être ravitailler que par voie
aérienne selon nos informations l'armée
burkinabé aurait largué à part
hélicoptère des dizaines de tonnes de
vivres aux populations prisonnières des
terroristes ce mardi une insécurité
alimentaire qui touche également le
Niger voisin depuis le début de l'année
2022 les violences dans la région de
tilaberry ont augmenté de nombreux
nigériens quittent leur village pour
échapper aux terroristes et ceux qui
choisissent de rester tentent de faire
survivre leur commerce dans un contexte
très incertain reportage d'arol Girard
9h ce matin et encore personne devant
cette boucherie de tilaberry ces
dernières années les clients d'Abdoulaye
Ganga se sont raréfiés lui a décidé de
rester dans sa ville natale alors que
l'insécurité est grandissante cette
année
ça fait 36 ans que je suis bouger j'ai
commencé comme assistant d'un vieux
commerçant donc c'est devenu comme un
héritage le prix de la viande a plus que
triplé en disant a-t-il aberri et
atteint aujourd'hui les 5 euros le kilo
lui essaie de maintenir des tarifs
abordables dans un pays où le salaire
moyen d'un individu est évalué autour de
50 euros
même si tout est devenu cher en ville il
n'a pas changé le prix et aujourd'hui
personne d'autre ne fait ça dans la
seule région de tilaberry plus de 140
incidents violents ont été répertoriés
depuis le début de l'année 2022 contre
93 sur l'ensemble de l'année 2021 les
éleveurs les plus vulnérables fuient et
laissent souvent les bouchers comme
Abdoulaye sans solution maintenant c'est
très difficile d'obtenir du bétail en
quantité il y a des endroits qui ne sont
plus accessibles on se débrouille
trouver de quoi travailler avant on
pouvait aller très loin dans les
villages pour acheter des bêtes
maintenant on doit se contenter des
alentours de Tillabéri des alentours qui
n'échappent pas à la menace djihadiste
d'autant plus que la situation
sécuritaire chaotique au Mali voisin
favorise les actions terroristes sur le
territoire nigérien
parce que de frontière actuellement
depuis le début donc si ça se détériom
au Mali pour savoir que nous attendons
que ça cherche à se détériés du côté du
Niger mais nous espérons qu'aujourd'hui
la nouvelle coopération
avec barkhane va permettre à nos forces
de sécurité de pouvoir faire
efficacement face à toute forme
d'impulsion le Niger a récemment
renforcé ses liens avec ses partenaires
internationaux sur le plan militaire
notamment la France et l'Allemagne mais
également au niveau régional comme avec
le Bénin au mois de juillet
en Guinée le procès des massacres du 28
Septembre 2009 s'est poursuivi ce mardi
à Conakry après l'ouverture il y a une
semaine il avait été reporté pour
permettre aux avocats des différentes
parties de mieux se préparer pour cette
deuxième journée de débat tous les
inculpés étaient présents dans la salle
d'audience dont le capitaine Moussa
Dadis Camara la correspondance à Conakry
de Malik Diakité
pour cette deuxième journée le débat a
été très tendu entre les avocats de la
défense le parquet et les avocats de la
partie civile concernant la mise en
liberté provisoire du capitaine Moussa
Dadis Camara d'abord le président du
tribunal a appelé à la barre le colonel
montatier bolo Camara l'onde d'être très
proche de l'excès de la gente Moussa
Dadis Camara au moment des massacres
interrogé sur le fait l'inculpé a rejeté
en bloc toutes les accusations prenons
la parole elles ont après les autres les
avocats de la défense ont tous dénoncé
je cite des irrégularités dans les
procédures judiciaires notamment les
détention abusives pour certains
inculpés incarcérées depuis 13 ans les
avocats de Moussa Dadis Camara quant à
eux réclame la mise en résidence
surveillée de l'ex-chef de la zone à
défaut d'être libéré nous avions demandé
au tribunal criminel de dixine et bien
vouloir relever les irrégularités qui
ont entaché l'arrestation et la
détention
du président Moussa Dadis Camara et en
conséquence ordonnée leur remise en
liberté immédiate et nous avons foi aux
arguments que nous avons développé et
nous osons espérer que le tribunal fera
droit sur notre demande pour le parquet
et les avocats de la partie civile pas
question d'une libération pour Moussa
Dadis Camara dès lors que l'article 252
indique il doit se consulter prisonnier
nous estimons que pour une question
d'écouter à l'égard de ces autres
co-accuser il est important qu'il reste
en prison il n'y a pas de traitement de
faveur à accorder à qui que ce soit
étant donné les charges lourdes qui
paient sur Moussa Dadis Camara et c'est
quoi accusé donc c'est vrai que justice
à la loi a été respectée pour pour sa
conduite au niveau de la maison d'arrêt
de Conakry dans le box des accusés les
11 prévenus étaient tous présents au
tribunal Moussa Dadis Camara le chef de
la gente au moment des faits devrait
plaider non coupable selon son avocat
elle s'appelle route backbee cette jeune
ivoirienne et championne du monde de
taekwondo elle a décroché la médaille
d'or au Grand Prix de Paris et son
succès en inspire beaucoup en disant le
nombre de licenciés à triplés en Côte
d'Ivoire la fédération de taekwondo en
compte aujourd'hui plus de 50 000 dans
plus de 350 clubs c'est le deuxième
sport du pays après le football notre
correspondante à Abidjan est allé à la
rencontre de la championne reportage
des dizaines d'enfants kimono qui
trépignent d'un patience ils attendent
leur idole route Magby
à 27 ans elle vient de décrocher la
médaille d'or au Grand Prix de Paris une
récompense qu'elle tient un partage et
avec son club d'enfance
c'est important pour moi de partager
parce que déjà
je suis on va dire une figure
emblématique de mon pays il y a beaucoup
de jeunes qui me regardent et qui
veulent faire comme moi donc moi c'est
important de partager mon expérience
pour les inspirer davantage dans leur
dans la réalisation de leurs rêves il
rêve tous de marcher dans ses pas dès le
plus jeune âge ils s'affrontent en duel
s'entraîne sous l'oeil attentif de
Monsieur Georges c'est lui qui a conduit
ou jusqu'au haut niveau pour 5000 francs
Cfa soit moins de 10 euros par mois
c'est petit taekwondo East apprennent
l'agilité et la rapidité face à leur
adversaire mais Maître Georges mais
surtout l'accent sur le respect et la
bienséance le taekwondo il y a le côté
sportif il y a le côté éducation ils ont
des matières théoriques ils ont des
matières pratiques quand on les évalue
donc ça veut dire que on donne un
enseignement de base d'éducation d'abord
à ses enfants
un sport qui plaît au plus jeune mais
aussi aux anciennes générations c'est
dans ce temple l'un des plus grands
d'Afrique que route s'entraîne quand
elle rentre au pays
aujourd'hui elle partage le Dow Jong
avec Jean-Marc yacet président de la
Fédération ivoirienne de taekwondo et
maire de Cocody il a commencé le
taekwondo lorsqu'il était dans l'armée
une pratique obligatoire pour tous les
militaires c'est en partie à cause de ça
que le sport est devenu si populaire
pour lui sa discipline qui conclut de 50
000 licenciés est un atout pour le
développement de la Côte d'Ivoire
ça a permis à recadrer les gens
certaines personnes qui le faisaient
d'abord un pour pouvoir faire autre
chose sur son recadrer recentrer pour
dire que non voilà ils étudiaient où ils
ont ils enseignaient ils se calmaient et
ça nous orientait les uns et les autres
je pense que c'est bénéfique c'est à ma
sœur en disant le nombre des licenciés à
triplé et avec les Jeux Olympiques 2024
les Ivoiriens espèrent avoir encore plus
de médailles
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique restez avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]